la mesure de suppression d affichage
propre audacieux en matière de films
érotiques répond sans doute au souhait
d'une large fraction de la population
mais si l'on constate qu'en 1974
pour la seule région parisienne ces
films ont totalisé plus de 6 millions
d'entrées
il est permis de croire que ceux là même
que choc l'affichage des films érotiques
constituent une bonne partie de leur
clientèle
personne ne peut donc penser sans
hypocrisie qu'une ville heureuse doivent
s'interdire le sexe le spectacle de
chair suggestives ou habilement dévoilé
ne constituant pas à la réflexion
une agression plus graves que d'autres
ex est couramment admis dans le monde
telles que la violence la guerre la
justice
déjà en ce qui concerne septième art la
bataille du sexe perd de son actualité
puisque le cinéma érotique en devenant
un phénomène de société s'intègre de
plus en plus au cinéma toujours et pour
être tout à fait sincère le plus gênant
dans ces affiches ne réside pas dans
leurs aspects prometteur on ne voit pas
pourquoi en effet le spectateur se
verraient interdire le droit d'être allé
chez le plus chaud qu'en lâchant le goût
se situe souvent au niveau des petits
tas offensant sinon pour les bonnes
moeurs
en tout cas pour les femmes tout se
passe comme si du lit qu'elle doive
faire pendant les heures de ménage
quotidien à celui où l'appétit d'un
metteur en scène roues et les couches
tout se passe comme si les femmes ne
méritais rien d'autre que d'être
constamment représentés dans le
spectacle de la rue comme de purs objets
de consommation
c'est pour elle quelque chose
d'avilissant on ne peut que souhaiter
une prise de conscience qui leur
proposent enfin au niveau de la
publicité des films et de la publicité
en général une image d'elle qui cessent
de porter atteinte à la dignité de
chacun et à la leur en particulier